do you know how we would be moving if we
ain't had that backbone 100 we wouldn't
be able to do what we're doing i was
married when i when i when i caught
none of my case i went married and none
of that [ __ ]
you heard like
none of that [ __ ] like
yo yo like your wife
every real man need a queen you gotta
had it you gotta have that backbone
like
you gotta had it that's that's balance
and that's the sanity and that's that
that's that um
you know your accountability
that's your accountability partner for
real yeah like your wife can hold you
accountable ain't nobody gonna tell the
truth like a woman or a child women and
kids they tell the truth ain't nothing
better than a woman's intuition every
time my wife told me a [ __ ] was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what's crazy that's the same
[ __ ] with my girl my girl will tell me
some [ __ ]
and then i won't listen and she's always
right i'm like man
yes it's crazy just like my mama it's
crazy how that is though whenever my
mama told me she ain't like one of my
homies she something happened and then i
ain't like no more youth hmm
my mom ain't never been wrong about no
[ __ ] i ever brought around her my old
lady ain't never been wrong about not
one [ __ ] that i ever brought around her
at all